[Music]
hey what's up guys
welcome back to culture binge the
wisecrack podcast where we get all types
of involved at what's going on in the
current cultural zeitgeist
i'm michael here as always with
wisecrack researcher serbia serbia how
are you today
i'm well thank you how are you good um
and wisecrack vanguard alec
alec how are things with you today i'm
great thank you for calling me that
awful name
yeah you know though the leader of a
philosophical movement
you're the leader of wisecrack i think
we all think of wisecrack as a large
philosophical movement
we have a lot to talk about today
there's lots of things happening lots of
topics to break down
we are going to talk about entitled
influencers we'll talk a little bit
about uh puff pieces and documentary
and we will talk about i'll put this
kindly um
work zoom etiquette in relation to
personal sexuality
um but before we go any further uh
we're gonna do slaps and once again not
chaps and that's because
enough things chap right now in the
world that we don't need to add any more
negative energy to anyone's life
um no negative vibes so if everyone's
cool to play by those rules
um let's just talk about what slaps with
no chaps
serbia what's something that's just
slapping in your life
i've been watching a lot of netflix like
really good netflix
um it all like started with emily in
paris so that's been great
um and it's just continued i've been
watching a telenovela
and i love it it's a really great time
on netflix
yeah well so what did you think about
for emily in paris with you what was
that journey like of watching that show
i'm just curious
so i i don't like the the character
emily um
but i like the other she's girl she
she's just like she there's no like no
character development or growth and
she's kind of oblivious
and i don't know i don't i didn't like
her but i liked
i liked the story of like an idea of
american
girl going to paris and then just like
playing into
every single stereotype um
and i just loved the images of paris it
felt like i was traveling and
i think i wanted an escape and to feel
like i was sitting there
with my baguette and my cheese so
it was nice it was it was really
um what i needed in the last couple of
weeks to make me feel like
i wasn't here in lockdown
that's good i yeah once i also binged
that show and started being like how do
people like this and ended thinking
i need more of this directed and you
know injected directly into me so
that's a good one um alec how about
yourself what are some slaps
uh this is probably late to the game
this is a very trendy thing to
read uh like early in the pandemic but
the great influenza by i think john
berry
uh i'm like a quarter way through it's a
really good book check it out if you
haven't already
uh it explains how america was a
horrible backwater of medicine for a
very long time which i find very amusing
wow um well that sounds good if not a
little serious
um i will say something that i think
slaps and i haven't finished it yet i
started reading a new book that came out
by one of my favorite
american singer song writers jeff tweedy
who's the front man of the band wilco
the book is called how to write one song
um
and it's not really just about how to
write a song it's sort of about the
creative process
in general how someone who's been pretty
creatively profound and productive like
him approaches
being creative and sort of like not
judging himself and making stuff and i
found it really cool and i know a lot of
people
uh because they spend more time at home
might have been taking on creative
projects recently so
worth checking out how to write one song
don't
read that book if you expect anything
more than that um
so good there's some positive stuff look
into those things let's not be negative
but speaking of people who sometimes
maybe get a little bit negative
and chap a lot of people's asses serbia
you're gonna you're gonna teach us
something about contemporary influencer
culture and i'm kind of excited to hear
about this so what do you got for us
so most of us are familiar with
influencers
um for those of you who aren't
influencers are individuals who use
social media to promote
their personal brand but they also get
paid for
sponsored posts and for years
influencers have popped up
in every hobby or interest gaming
beauty makeup whatever it is there's an
influencer for it
and while many organizations use
influencer marketing as a tactic to
increase
brand awareness and audience engagement
there are businesses that are absolutely
done with the age of the influencer so
here's how influencer marketing works
there are two main ways so one way
is that an influencer has enough
followers
to get signed with an agency and
brands will come to the influencer
they'll say
we want you to post about this product
we'll pay you say one thousand dollars
you'll post it at this time
it'll include this many pictures and
it's it's transactional it's like a
business relationship
um the other way influencers get
involved with brands is that they
approach businesses
and they'll say i have
500 000 followers let me know if you
want to collaborate
or if you send me free products i'll
give you a post
for brand exposure and the worst thing
that these the second way
is that they'll they'll approach
businesses in real life so they'll go to
like a bakery and be like oh i'll give
you
uh i'll give you like free exposure if
you give me this cake for free
um so they'll just do it right on the
spot and in the past
year i've seen and heard more businesses
express dissatisfaction with influencers
they've said that they're greedy and
entitled and specifically small
businesses
are upset because small businesses have
small profit margins so when influencers
ask for free stuff the impact on the
business's bottom line is significant
so this anti-influencer sentiment has
been growing
in the pandemic and we're all aware of
how difficult the pandemic and the
lockdowns have been
on both individuals and businesses and
the worst thing is that businesses have
started to say that they've seen
an uptick in the number of influencers
who are asking for free items
so not only are businesses struggling
because people aren't coming into the
door but now they have the people who
are coming into the door asking for free
stuff
so before i hear your thoughts on
influencer marketing i want
to share a couple of examples so i know
an influencer
who has i think two or three million
followers and her entire life is
sponsored
like she had a wedding and everything
from the flowers
the cake the her clothes her shoes
everything
was given to her and
she's that influencer who both has
brands come to her
and she also approaches bran so like for
her photographer
she sent links to her social media
accounts and said let me know if you
want to collaborate i'm getting married
next month and even when she bought a
new house she had the entire house
sponsored by local businesses
do you personally know this person or
this is just somebody on the internet
i actually went to this wedding wow
was it the coolest wedding ever no or
the corniest wedding ever
i mean it was nice but it was very much
like at the reception it was like and
i'd like to thank this brand
for giving me this and i'd like to thank
that person for this and um
it felt like i was at a sponsored event
like i felt like i was
like it's some sort of industry party
and like at the reception there was like
a
i think there was like a sign that said
something like candles and
decor provided by brand um
so it it felt very very gross anyway
so uh like her house like she's had
painters and whoever come and like paint
the house in exchange for
uh exposure and my hair stylist told me
that she had an influencer approach
her saying that if she gave her a free
haircut and color
which i think was like a total of like
250 dollars
that she would post this on her social
channels
and my hair stylist is just like she's
like a single
mom i think and she just doesn't have a
ton of money
to put into marketing so she was
interested in how this works but she
said a few people called
nobody came in and she wished that she
had done something different
to market herself and while i think that
influencer marketing
is it can be done well
when done strategically it can be
impactful and beneficial for businesses
but i do think the people of asking for
free things especially
people who can afford to pay full price
is repugnant and i prefer a more
professional
and structured approach to influencer
marketing
with both parties understanding what
they'll receive so it's not just
give me a free lip gloss and i'll post
it on
insta it's let's talk about
what the messaging is who are you trying
to reach what is your audience like what
are the ingredients of this
and does your business and do your
ethical standards align with my personal
goals
um anyway i was really grossed out to
hear that it's gotten worse during the
pandemic what are your thoughts
well there's a business i like a lot in
los angeles that's called
cvt soft serve this is not sponsored
content
um but i and just for example i i hate
dessert but i love soft serve ice cream
i think it's the only good way to eat
ice cream and i think scooped ice cream
is hard cementy trash and i don't
understand why
i agree with uh um and also
vegan soft service so much better than
vegan scooped ice cream but that said
um there's this business and it runs out
of la it's a dude that owns a couple
trucks
and they do soft-serve at events or on
street corners and
uh a dude that just like owns a business
himself he runs it with his wife they
have a few kids
and he will get these emails that say
things like hi i work for this celebrity
or this influencer
we're doing a big event we can't pay you
but wondering if you could come out and
do ice cream for great exposure
and he gets these all the time and he'll
post them on his instagram and then his
responses which are like [ __ ] you i run
a small business
you don't you know i don't know you [ __ ]
and then he's had people come up to the
truck before
and literally just be like hi can i have
this ice cream but i'm an influencer so
i'll take pictures do i not have to pay
um
and it's worth looking at his instagram
because his responses are great and
there's another business in los angeles
i like called burgers never say die
not sponsored content it's just the best
goddamn hamburger in los angeles
and um they have a huge sign up at their
business that says
like influencers [ __ ] off and they've
especially said during the pandemic it's
like they're barely
able to keep their business going and
yet people are still asking them for
free [ __ ]
um i really hate it i think it's such a
bad look and i think like you said
serbia i guess it's one thing
to have a partnership with a brand or a
corporation i still think that's like
corny and i don't like it but like
sometimes we gotta do what we gotta do
in this world
but to just roll up to a business
especially a small business and demand
free [ __ ] because you have a lot of
online followers
it's just the dumbest thing ever it's
such a bad look
and i think it it's kind of a i guess a
toxic approach to what it means to have
like notoriety or fame or whatever it
might be
you know like i don't know matthew
mcconaughey is famous and he would never
do that so it's just like
be like him i don't know yeah
uh i feel like there's an intoxicating
effect to getting free [ __ ]
like the few times i've been at events
where i'm like pampered with
free [ __ ] and have you know been like oh
i work for a youtube channel with
thank you you know give me this uh 200
gift card uh but that was like at a
place where
uh i'm not gonna excuse the behavior but
it was at least out of thing where
people were there to pander to youtube
influencers even though i'm not yeah you
didn't demand it you didn't run up to
the table and say please give me free
money
yeah they asked you i played it yeah
they're like how many subscribers do you
have and i was like uh
i uh maybe have like two million um see
vanguard of the channel are you ever on
camera uh one time i was
uh so um
so it's intoxicating like i think for
anyone i don't think anyone's above
like that but i think i wonder what
percentage of this is just like
that intoxication fueled by like a
narcissism that's like give me free [ __ ]
all the time
because i mean uh jacob who i love
dearly was so amazing like
he'd uh you know just message everyone
being like hey
uh do you want to like donate this
equipment to us and then like you know
we'll like post about you on social
media and these were larger companies
um and as someone like not looking at
the budget or anything i was like this
is sweet like you know we've we've got
like cool new headphones and stuff and
we'll plug them in whatever
um at the same time i understand that
that's very bad
uh the other end of it is that i think a
lot of people are trying to be
influencers now because they probably
are working from home or have maybe lost
their jobs and are trying to
reinvent their life didn't we talk about
someone who was trying to reinvent their
life as a travel influencer in this life
or something yeah yeah or somebody sent
us an email
uh about this horribly hairy
sister yeah or something yeah or cousin
and so i think there's probably a lot
more of that where it's like hey i have
like 500 followers you want to give me
free ice cream and i think that's pretty
terrible but also it's not new
i i read like even three four maybe even
five years ago there's articles about
hotels getting sick of influencers
asking for free rooms and everyone
shutting down so i think we're
kind of perpetually at war with
influencers
i have i don't so the example with jacob
asking for free things
when it's like a large company it
doesn't bother you
it doesn't bother me like but if it's
something it's like a small business
i don't like that at all because it's
it's actually like a human
we're trying to make money yeah if
there's like some gamer
and best buy gives them some hardware
headphones whatever best buy is a
multi-billion dollar company they can
afford some [ __ ] who cares
but yeah when it's you know like i said
before a dude with two ice cream trucks
or a tiny burger shop and a strip mall
owned by an individual
like [ __ ] off they should not be giving
you stuff
i also i just looked around the skype
box and we're all using the same uh
rode microphone that that was given to
us but but thank you shout outs
to rogue shout out i legitimately like
this microphone so thank you road
but this is also but this is a
functional relationship because
they create audio products we use them
to create
quality content it's not like we're just
like hey can i have a sandwich
like there's like there's so you know
serbia used this terminology before of
do you want to collab
and i think that's an interesting frame
for this right because there's certain
partnerships
where collaboration makes sense so let's
say it's like a famous chef
does a collaboration with a hot sauce
company and it looks good for the hot
sauce company because the famous chef
uses it the famous chefs is like oh
here's how i use this in some of my food
and it might be a little corny but
there's a genuine relationship between
the brand
yeah of course they're getting paid um
but you know at least i'm like okay this
makes sense
but if it's like just a person who wants
to collab with like
i don't know a sushi restaurant it's
like what does this have to do
with anything you're just a person this
is just sushi i don't need you two to
have a symbiotic relationship
yeah i think that's the thing it's like
if it if it benefits
both of us and if i'm going to get paid
for something and it's not about money
but it's just the fact that it feels
more like a business relationship rather
than
me getting free stuff and feeling like a
moocher i think that's what it is like
the oh this is a business relationship
and also get free things versus like i
just walk around asking everyone for
free [ __ ]
i think i think i think maybe that's
what it is because
you know uh i i follow various like
instagram sort of like vegan like
restaurants and i'm sure
like you know they're going to different
vegan restaurants across new york city
and getting free food and taking
pictures and posting it
and to be honest like i will probably go
more like i'm more likely to go to those
restaurants as a result
but i think you know if they're emailing
these people and possibly even you know
getting paid or
doing this in the business context
versus showing up randomly and being
like hey give me a free sandwich
yeah and i think there's a thing too
where like i don't want to be too
cynical in that
i don't know for example if there was
like a great restaurant
in my city that was like oh we love
wisecrack
um yeah we know that you like here yeah
but if they were
but they were like hey will you do a
thing where um on a wisecrack video
um burns is going to take a bite of our
burrito every 10 minutes and just like
shout us out
if it was my favorite place i'd be this
works for both of us because this is a
establishment which is genuinely good
that i really like
and they really like our channel that'd
be really weird if a cool burrito place
like wisecrack if that's you reach out
but you know i i think there are things
like that or like when
a great musician does a sponsored
content with like fender guitars it's
like well yes
this musician was probably playing that
guitar anyways now they just get to like
work
with the brand so i think stuff like
that makes sense just to make sure i'm
not being too cynical right but i think
most of what happens on instagram i do
find to not be that
and to be like hanger on lecture is
[ __ ] yeah
i agree i think that it it just depends
on on how
the approach works like if it's the
business approaching you that seems cool
but it's like you just going out and
saying hey klm
airlines wanna find me for free which i
know i've said multiple times and
haven't
heard back it's getting uncomfortable we
will all sync this
offer the opportunity i just want
everyone listening to know that
um but but i think i think it depends
like
on the approach if it's a business like
i want to give wisecrack free stuff i'd
be like cool
like if we like it and if you're ethical
and cool like why not use it
yeah but i guess do you think serbia
that one of the problems
is that like a younger culture of
influencers
didn't come up in that era of more kind
of like collaborative brand deals
so in their mind it's just like i'm
popular me get free thing
i think what i mean i think for at least
some proportion of people it's that
i think there is like a growing like
sense of entitlement
where people think like well if this is
my job like you should be grateful to
work with me and have exposure
yeah i think the thing too that bums
people out is like
you know if i don't know i'm trying to
give an example
um i don't know if bill murray goes to
oh he did this actually bill murray went
to the ice cream truck i'm thinking of
but like if bill murray goes to an ice
cream truck and they might be like oh
[ __ ] yeah bill murray we'll give you
free ice cream because you are literally
a legend uh in your field and someone
people love
but then some influencer even if they
have 10 million followers show up i do
think a lot of businesses are like i
don't know what the [ __ ] you are
um you're not entitled to what bill
murray or
sophia loren or the barefoot contessa
or i don't know another random celebrity
can also just work just follow like you
can
get sort of like click yeah to follow
you and be like oh i have 100
i see this on twitter all the time
people with 50 000 followers and every
tweet gets like three likes
yeah and i think that's the problem
right i think for a lot of businesses
illicitly smaller ones it's like what do
you even do
like why am i giving you things what's
your talent yeah and i know that's a
little reductive and i know marketing is
a talent and branding
is a skill i guess but i think that's
the hard thing if it's you know once
again
if the guitar company is like hey we're
gonna give john mayer guitar stuff it's
like that makes sense he's very talented
at this thing
but if you're just someone who has
followers like i don't know
what's your skill what are you doing at
the talent show what makes you special
why should god love you i don't want to
hate completely on influencers because
there
has been a movement um i think it was
called like pay our way
where travel influencers were encouraged
to just pay for their own travel
and just talk about the brands and the
hotels and the airlines that they love
because they can afford to pay for it
and there was another one that was like
eat out to help out or something
and that was go eat at small businesses
or go eat at restaurants that you love
and post about it for free
i mean not that not that influencers are
journalists but i mean i think there
should be
there's also the sort of conflict of
interest and that like
if you're being given this for free or
you know getting the the hotel paid for
are you going to give it an actually
objective review
whereas like yeah the best travel
implant influencers telling you about
the good hotels and best airlines
are probably the ones who don't have
that conflict of interest
and i think they're like everyone is
kind of an influencer so i'm sure
there's lots of
like you know beauty youtubers who are
like really good at doing makeup
are like very interesting talented
people uh
and if they're giving recommendations
and you're looking for makeup to
purchase you know you might hope that
they're not
you know they they are at least
separating what is a paid advertisement
from what they're doing
yeah and then it's that question of like
were you in the game before this so if
you're someone who's already an expert
at makeup stuff
then and like the art of that then you
start making content then you get
partnerships well that's great you were
already doing that if you're someone
that already had a passion
for travel or culture or food and then
you translate it into
partnerships to me that makes more sense
than just like i started getting
partnerships because i post pictures
where i look
dank or something yeah then it's like
why do i care about your stuff that's
also a skill once again but i just think
maybe
if like your whole talent is looking
dank then i i don't know what product
does they're just jealous that none of
us know how to look dank
i think we all look dank uh
mean god sir you never did drugs in the
2000s
yeah okay well before we buy any any
final thoughts on this and
any any you know please that we want to
make
to potential sponsors to sell our souls
for free
besides serbia who will do anything for
klm
yeah i would
[Laughter]
if you're an influencer write in i'd
love to hear your thoughts am i wrong
yeah we will we'll we'll be uh
empathetic
we we don't hate there's like the the
straw man influencer
that's easy to hate and then all the
yeah sort of people in between who
actually are doing cool there's a
[ __ ] guy who makes like pottery on
tick tock who's an influencer
he's really good at pottery and he's
probably super cool happy
for that guy to get all the free clay
you know yeah yeah pottery guy
hit us up um skateboarding cranberry
juice fleetwood mac
guy hit us up that's my favorite anyone
that guy rules um
yeah so that's great and and truly if
you are an influencer we'd love to
talk to you about that as long as you
don't suck but if you've ever rolled up
at my favorite ice cream or burger place
you do not get to speak on us
ever or speak to us ever so speaking of
um
influential activity online i wanted to
quickly talk about
a i guess a current event topic uh and
this is something that happened
this week um and it's a little mishap
that happened at a
zoom meeting of the staff of the new
yorker magazine they were doing a mock
um i think was a mock election debate or
a mock debate of some sort
i think they were trying to figure out
like what all the different angles like
you had to role play as like a
conservative journalist or something
yeah i don't fully understand it so
don't but
it's fine and we do this said why is
we're role-playing most days um
but a legal uh analyst and journalist
by the name of jeffrey toobin he you
might know me goes on cnn a lot he
writes for the new yorker amongst other
places published a lot of books
during this meeting they went on a break
he thought
that he was like muted from zoom like as
if like the call was done so no one
could see or hear him
during this time he then jumped on
another
call that was either with a uh
breakout room oh you're sorry i go ahead
i don't mean to [ __ ] up your stuff
oh yeah yeah so there was breakout rooms
happening on the zoom meeting he thought
he was not
still alive he thought because there was
breakout sessions
his camera and audio were not currently
engaged he moved his screen down a
little bit
he then on another device um got on a
call
of sorts i think there's some thought
that it might have been like a a cam
situation i don't think anyone knows for
sure
and then he proceeded to one could say
go
tubin by himself um
let's be okay [ __ ] he masturbated um
and
while he thought he was on not actively
working
he was on zoom the whole time so his
colleagues at the new yorker
were able to see him masturbating
on screen so and then he well i'll just
finish by saying this
and then he popped back on um
unaware so he just opened his computer
back up and was like
yeah so the thing about the supreme
court is and his colleagues
had just seen him go to town on himself
here's my question i i well first of all
let's just get out of the way don't
don't crank it during zoom meetings
anyone men
women it's just just don't do it but
what's yes sex negative don't enjoy
anything
like i think the the timeline matters a
lot like
was he jerking it to his colleagues
because i don't know that we know no he
was he was not yeah i think we know that
he was not drinking it to his colleagues
i think he was jerking it to a
a third-party entity and i think it was
either he was having phone sex
or he was on like a cam website where he
was
paying a sex worker to as the kids say
talk him off but was this like
you know let's say you've got your video
off you're on a call you're making lunch
uh not everyone needs to know that
you're making lunch whatever yeah uh
or was this what was it that kind of
situation where he's like i don't need
to be super engaged in this call so i'm
gonna like play xbox
which again i know it's not comparable
or was this truly like
this is my lunch break because yeah
sorry so there's varying accounts of
this the so the story broke
via vice also i'll just say this too who
snitched
at the new yorker staff you know keep
the drama inside the house
well okay i i know i don't know i've
mixed thoughts about it
uh but but details have sort of like
trickled out
um or shot out and what we
know is that so it sounds like what was
happening is
there was a general zoom meeting then
there was breakouts
and that he was not a part of the
breakout
so that in his mind okay i'm gonna kind
of put my computer
to the side before the meeting comes
back
and during that time you know one could
make a sandwich
one could take a power nap or one could
furiously masturbate without knowing
they're on screen
but it sounds like and i guess i'm
giving him a little bit of the benefit
of the doubt here
that he seems to have thought
that he was on a break of sorts from
work
and that no one could see him so so i
guess here's my my thought my question
for all of you right
would this be different if it was like
a delivery person who
in between deliveries went home
masturbated washed up and then got back
after it i guess delivery person
is a weird choice for me to have made
because now you're thinking of that
person touching your food that's what
i'm saying well i
i think the better one is one of my
friends used to work in midtown and like
he would smoke around the corner from
basically like an adult video shop where
they have little booths
and he just see like tech bros going in
like you know during their lunch breaks
to
to go to this adult video shop to to
crank one out and go back to work
um i'm not gonna i mean
i i think it's important to frame like
the a lot of the reactions which i think
are totally justified is like this is
the behavior of like
predators and i think if stuff would
come out like jeffrey toobin's always
cranking the network and always trying
to accidentally express himself to
like not cool like there's that level of
it
um but also like i
you know without a pattern of behavior
it's it's maybe i i think it's easy to
give him that narrative of that like
you know he's cranking and getting off
on the fact that his co-workers are on
the call and there's like a sexual
predator element to that and i don't
want to discount that theory
but the other one is like yeah if you're
a tech bro who likes to
whack it on his lunch break uh or like
to be honest like during college like i
knew people
women who would like have bad cramps and
crank it
in in the women's bathroom and so i'm
not going to excuse me
yeah let me offer i want to hear what
serbia thinks about this i just want to
give a little just more of the broader
context as well for this
is that the past 48 hours of the
discourse online about this has been
very interesting because
the first wave was oh my god this
happened ha ha that's so funny
second wave this is really gross what a
piece of [ __ ] third wave was
actually this is just indicative of how
work from home creates these really
weird boundaries and we shouldn't shame
someone
for cranking it on their work break
because we should be sex posi
and then now i think like this morning
it's shifted back to
oh cool so now we're defending 60 year
old men who pull their dicks out on zoom
calls yeah so that's been like the cycle
particles unless that's your job if
you're a sex worker and that's your job
you can do that sorry serve not your job
don't do it
okay so serbia what do you think so i've
worked remotely for years and i've used
zoom for a really long time
and i i think that
working from home you should still treat
it like it's a professional
environment so i understand that you're
at home your kids are gonna run around
you're gonna need to like
move your laundry around or whatever and
that's fine but when you're in a
a call you should try to be as present
as possible
and not not like touch yourself in a
call
yeah so i agree i don't think that like
that's an okay excuse to be like oh we
should be sex positive like i'm
totally sex positive but i but i think
the chronology question is like
yeah was he doing it during the call or
was he doing this like
basically not his lunch break exactly
but like
yeah i don't want to pull like a ross
and rachel but if they were on a break
then i feel like were they on a break or
were they in breakout rooms
we don't we i i think the bigger ones
existed but
what is we don't know if he was a part
of one yeah right he should have been
though right
like why are you such a boss who's like
he should be working
maybe he wasn't a part of it maybe there
was a breakout i'm not
to be clear i'm not standing up for this
guy i'm simply saying there is
a possible we don't know all the details
there's a possible series of events
where there was a main event
there was breakouts and he wasn't a part
of that so he was legit
on a break for a bit but just left zoom
on
until it came back well it doesn't
matter though
like if you're in that call it doesn't
matter if he wasn't a part of a breakout
room or not he was still in a call that
time was still blocked off for work
so yeah to me i think it's i
don't care that he was working at home i
don't care about anything
like i feel like if you're supposed to
be working during that time i expect you
to not touch yourself
yeah so i
mostly i agree with serbia but i the the
reason i actually find this
not even to like litigate i feel like
litigating what
jeffrey toobin's like non innocence is
maybe a little less interesting yeah but
i think what is more interesting
is the the lack of boundaries because i
think you know this is a clear case of
like don't whack it during work calls
you know et cetera et cetera but
consider there's like lots of other
examples like what everyone's been on a
conference call with like 20 people and
are doing something else it could be
playing xbox it could be cooking food
they could be taking a [ __ ] right um and
then it's like
what happens when that comes on you know
people take lunch breaks people have
their own time
what if you know you work in your
bedroom and decide to like
have a lunch break with your partner and
like get freaky
like the problem and just for the kids
out there get freaky what alec meant by
there's a euphemism for sex so if you
were born in like the mid 90s early
2000s that's what he meant by that just
so you know
i i think like it's easy to say that
like
i i mean like i think kind of what
serbia's saying is like listen from nine
to five or ten to six or however long
you work like that's work time and like
don't do any of that stuff but i think
you know as you know during the pandemic
and just working from home
those things become collapsed because
you know even if you're saying from nine
to five you're not gonna have sex you're
not gonna whack it
you're still allowed to poop that's fine
um
what if you have a call at like 7 p.m
like those boundaries are constantly
shifting and so like even if the jeffrey
tube in case is super cut and dry like
[ __ ] that dude he's cranking it during a
work call that is not cool
and i think that it might be what's
happening uh
i think it still raises this like
complete lack of distinction i don't
know
serbia if you understand it yeah no but
i just i think there's something
to that survey
i muted myself um is my volume back yeah
that's fine
okay uh so i think that the distinction
is that if
it's fine if you want to do that during
work hours
the problem is that he decided to do it
when he was in a work
call so like i think you should treat
being in a zoom room as if you're in an
actual physical room
so until you click that leave button you
should be as professional as possible
and like i don't care if your kids are
running around like that's fine
but it's this other thing is the problem
so if somebody like gets off the call
and starts like touching themselves
whatever like i take naps for three
hours during the day
um whoa cut that if servie's bosses hear
this this is she knows
she's like she's like did you wake up
are you awake yet i'm like yeah i just
woke up
um so i think we we
you're you're when you work at home your
personal life and your professional life
do blend
but you should still have some decency
to not do that
when you're in a world i don't mean to
destroy that jerry i'm sorry
i just i think that it's incredibly
disrespectful in this whole like he
didn't know he was on camera
well like you were like i the
there's no excuse for that yeah for sure
and i think just to maybe
maybe i'm like agreeing or sort of like
rephrasing some of what alec was saying
here
totally i don't think and i don't think
just to be clear if anyone's if you're
listening to this i don't think
any of us are saying like no it's cool
that he like
jayod when he was on a work call no one
thinks that
um i mean some people think that but we
don't but yeah i just think
it gets at maybe that idea of the
blurred lines these days with work from
home stuff and like i think serbia you
know you're someone who
coming if i'm wrong has just worked from
home in normal world
and alec as well and i think for a lot
of us working from home
has been a pandemic specific thing so it
does create
different vibes where like i don't know
when wisecrack had an office right
i could i would sometimes be like oh i'm
going to go
get lunch and a coffee and i would leave
for 30 minutes and like yeah
maybe if the grocery store bathroom was
open and there wasn't a line and i'm
kidding i never jerked off in a grocery
store bathroom but
um but you know i think there's like
there used to be this this sense at
which there was time and the other thing
i will say
i don't know i don't think this was the
case but there are companies out there
that are requiring their employees to
like stay logged in
all day now and to me like that brings
up like weird stuff like if my
company says i have to be logged in on
zoom all day to like prove that i'm
working
like what if i feel stressed and what if
a stress release for me is going in the
other room and just like
doing self-care on my penis and i don't
know so i just think like
the tubing thing for sure i just think
this does bring up some questions
about the the blurred lines of work
life balance in in our contemporary
moment
yeah and i think the only confusion for
me like i'm on board with serbia if
you're on a call if you think your
camera's off don't whack it
maybe maybe cook a meal even if you're
playing xbox maybe not the most
profession don't whack it
but like the question the distinction is
like did he think he logged off from
that
and he did not anyway i'm obsessive
about checking to make sure my camera is
off and my sound is off
because one time a couple years ago
i was i joined this call and like you
know how you have tabs open that like
will randomly just start like
start up again and like start like
shouting at you so this was a call it
was like super important like all hands
call
there were executives on the team and i
was reviewing
a thug notes video
and it was like what'd it do y'all and
the whole meeting stopped and it was
like
serbia would you um please mute yourself
yeah um well i i hate to do this shawl
we've we've i didn't realize how deeply
would go into tubin's tube but
um i think we we in general agree on
this would obviously love to hear what
people think about this as well
but i think we do need to move on so
sorry for that um we will do a dedicated
episode to
uh digital workplace masturbation soon
um but for now
another type of masturbatory thing you
could do is produce a documentary
about you that makes yourself look good
or that you have some say in and alec
i think this is the thing that's been
happening more recently that you wanted
to talk about
yeah and so i'm sure maybe some of you
know this
uh a lot of us have been watching the
vow uh obviously months ago we were
obsessed with tiger king
i even as a non-sports person enjoyed
the last dance there's a new
stars documentary also on nexium called
i forget what it's called but it seems
better
seduced yeah there's a lot of
documentaries especially on
netflix especially on hulu and there's
actually this really interesting article
that i encourage everyone to read it's
pretty long
from the columbia journalism review by
danny funt about
kind of like access only documentaries
uh like i think a thing that we don't
think about
when we watch these things is like how
did the filmmakers get access to these
people
and a lot of times it's basically quid
pro quo
um so this is a quote from the article
this golden age of documentaries is
defined in part by the blurring of what
it even means to be
a documentary 140 uh earlier he
he establishes that 147 million people
have watched at least one netflix
documentary
um they're very very big right now uh
but what's happening
is you know uh
filmmakers are making deals to get
access to the people that they are
documenting this isn't always the case
but examples that come up is there was a
hillary clinton documentary
um there they mentioned uh firefest and
firefest
you know there was a controversy because
uh [ __ ] jerry the the marketing company
and
whatever jerry's last name is was like
an executive producer on the firefest
documentary about the fraud that he did
and if you noticed that one very much
like excused him
and like him being a bad guy in that
scenario um
in the other firefest documentary billy
mcfarlane was paid
uh there's a bill gates documentary on
netflix i watched which i hated
called like decoding inside bill gates's
brain or decoding bill gates
um the filmmaker the director behind
that was this guy davis guggenheim
who had made a uh a pro charter school
documentary
uh which is one of bill gates's pet
causes uh
and also received funding that
documentary received funding from the
the gates campaign
so what's happening is that you know in
the case of hillary clinton and i'm just
using that because
it's well documented is the campaign
actually shot a ton of the footage
they met a filmmaker that they felt
comfortable with because they had sort
of ties to the democratic party
and so you know i think a lot of these
documentary makers will say
oh like i would never give my editorial
independence but there's this weird
relationship between i need access and
the person
giving that access will pick the people
friendly to them
uh might have like a financial
partnership with them might make
themselves an executive producer
and so it makes me sort of look back and
question like all of the things i'm
watching in the val where it seems like
the access
this guy mark vincente who is uh
basically the good guy
you know he's in the cult escapes the
cult takes the cult down
the documentary essentially absolves him
of any wrong doing and i think it's just
a
very interesting question of what do
these documentary filmmakers have to do
to get access to the people
that they're making documentaries about
yeah i mean i think the the vow and and
and secluded thing is
especially uh you know
apropos pointing here because when you
watch the vow like you said mark
and sarah and our guy nippy and bonnie
they seem like they're like
good but after finishing the vow i
learned that like mark vicente is
technically
or technically helped in like legit sex
trafficking minors
across borders um
well that's just like in legal documents
and i guess the deuce is going to get
into it
but yeah like the these people
were you know had their hands a lot
dirtier and even with like the case of
mark vincente like he was in
another cult before he joined nexium so
this is someone in the world
uh it's called i i i had it up earlier
it's like the something
fellowship it was a this woman in
washington state
and a god who was 660 thousand years old
spoke to her
and they used to like smoke cigs and
drink wine
to like get in the right vibe or
something and like lay out online party
it was super weird so but all that to
say is with the this the vow thing
of course and the gates documentary for
sure
and this kind of makes me think of
serbi's topic a little bit like the
the way in which in like influencer
culture the lines between
generally like genuinely endorsing a
product or being enthusiastic about an
experience it's hard to know if that's
objective now because of how much
content is sponsored
and it seems like the same thing has
happened in document documentary
filmmaking
is there any objectivity left or is
there always something sus
going on like this that makes it really
hard to figure out these days
serbia so i i
have had a hard time with documentaries
because of this and i
think that as soon as i realized like
they have like footage of like meetings
or like
inside information about stuff i'm
always like well how'd you get that like
did
are you a member like or did you promise
to like
let them have like a final review or
have some sort of like say
um i i prefer documentaries that are
more
like investigations after the fact like
that
going clear um is really interesting to
me or
um some of those are kind of neat are
like what's that other one oh the jinx
although that's not quite like a
documentary but something that's more of
like
investigation and like let's talk to a
bunch of people rather than like let's
somehow get our camera
and like interview the ceo of whatever
definitely i mean if you think of like
the work of louis theroux the british
documentary filmmaker whose stuff is on
various american streaming platforms but
when he made a movie on scientology and
he's someone that in the past has like
embedded himself in a lot of
weird and alternative communities
including like the westboro baptist
church and other stuff
but he wanted to make a scientology
movie and no one would talk to him but
he still
made a really interesting documentary
about scientology that was sort of
antagonistic and ended up
luring the scientologist to him because
he's a good documentary filmmaker
and didn't have to sort of like have
someone buy into it
or to sort of like make a deal with
someone to pay them to get
access and like in my mind that's what
it means to be a good documentarian
and i just feel like a lot of people
don't have that skill anymore or that
sort of like journalistic aspect
to that type of film but i don't even
think it's i mean obviously it's on the
directors and in this article there's
directors who are like whatever like
it's one thing if you're making
political propaganda but like who cares
if
you know michael jordan held on to the
footage from that last dance
documentary for two decades because he
was the one who had to clear
the clips of him you know playing cards
and doing all this [ __ ] but
um i don't agree with that sentiment
that like whatever it's not
propaganda like political propaganda who
cares but
uh i think
it's like a studio pressure right when
you're pitching netflix if you're to say
hey i've got this great investigative
documentary about like hillary clinton
and her campaign
maybe it's positive maybe it's negative
maybe you know it's neutral
but like i did a lot of research i'm
really smart and all that stuff they're
gonna be like great
who's attached to that that's really
famous who will get clicks like this is
a conversation whenever you're trying to
sell show whether it's a comedy show
or whatever it's like who's the massive
celebrity on it
and for the case of documentaries you
know it's like oh you got hillary
clinton to talk to you like [ __ ]
awesome or you got bill gates to talk to
you
whereas if you go in the room it's like
hey nobody knows my face i want to make
a documentary about bill gates
give me money you're you could succeed
but you can't and so
you know i'm not going to call these
documentary
filmmakers like evil like i think
they're just trying to get by in the
ecosystem that's been sort of created by
like how
stuff gets made sure but i will say well
didn't the documentary mine the gap
win an oscar and it's about some teenage
skateboarders from western illinois
uh maybe sure no i i just want to say
you know or like um
the uh honeyland which was an
oscar-nominated documentary last year is
about a macedonian woman who keeps bees
i don't know part of me i get what
you're saying alex but the devil's
advocate part of me wants to say
if you find a good enough story it
doesn't matter if there's a celebrity
attached people will care
and maybe sometimes having someone
attached is a lazy way to not actually
have
a good story and that's why like the
bill gates and hillary clinton
documentaries
both suck i'll just say it because
they're puff pieces for an influential
person
who they're just hagiography they're not
really documentaries right and i think
maybe
if they just call themselves like visual
hagiographies fine
but i feel like documentary implies
something that we're not getting sorry
sir you go ahead yeah
yeah like a documentary implies like an
independent
perspective and like a look at what's
going on from all sides
and that's not what this says yeah
i don't know i think maybe maybe
maybe people don't aren't into it maybe
we're
looking maybe we're analyzing it too
much like maybe people are excited to
watch a fluff piece about um
hillary clinton or bill i think they are
yeah like good enough for them because
i guess it's like it's the same sort of
thing like if you read certain
publications that have a specific
like political lien to them like i don't
watch certain things or read certain
publications because they don't align
with what i want
so maybe we want a more independent look
and other people are happy
with like i'm not expressing myself as
it sounded better in my head than it
does no no i think what you're saying
makes really good sense
don't make it well yeah i think a really
good example of this is the recent paris
hilton documentary that they put out on
netflix and has
tons of views and i think people wanted
to watch it because like
they find paris hilton interesting and i
like i watched it and thought it was
interesting
but then i did feel a little bummed and
after the fact i read about all the
things that weren't included and
aspects of her life that were included
was like okay like you know both things
are true
this is a documentary that she produced
about herself so of course she's gonna
look really good
um but it was vulnerable and got it some
real stuff also she's someone who has
like brazenly used the n-word over the
years and hasn't apologized
um and these are both like true
things um and recently i actually
watched the uh
documentary that damn dan harmon kind of
got produced about himself harmontown
um but that's one where i'm like okay he
gave the rights to it but he gave them
final cut so there's times in that
documentary where he straight up looks
like an alcoholic abusive [ __ ]
and at least like it's he kind of made a
documentary about himself which is some
narcissistic [ __ ]
but he truly kept in the bad so when you
watch this move you're like ugh
this guy's kind of funny and smart but
like kind of a dick who has some
problems
yeah i think you know there's an
interesting dichotomy in the article
which speaks to your point serbia but
if you're reading a book that's like the
autobiography of hillary clinton
you know as told to you know like you'll
dictate or speak to some sort of ghost
writer not a ghostwriter but just a
writer writer
it's like great like here's a biography
of hillary clinton by hillary clinton
like i this is what it is
but like the hillary clinton documentary
for instance was paused
like marketed as like a raw inside look
at hillary clinton like that people
don't get to see
when you know the article gets into you
know her team had
like edit notes on it they filmed most
of the footage to begin with
the the one of the people um behind it
they're like dad was a democratic
senator so hillary clinton even in like
allowing it
made like knew that like he was one of
the ones that you know she could trust
to tell like her kind of message
and so i don't think people going into
that are like oh the
or even the bill gates one like i didn't
i i had assumed i was just gonna get a
document about bill gates and i wasn't
expecting it to be
positive or negative or neutral but then
you know as i was watching i was like oh
this is like
clearly designed to just be like
propaganda
for bill gates and like watching over
like his stuff about like his anti-trust
and
you know all these other things and just
like you know it's a hagiography as
as burn said and i don't think that's
clear when you click on it like if i had
bought uh
bill gates biography as written by bill
gates
i'd be like okay like this is what i'm
supposed to expect
so it's like a misrepresentation of what
the
what you're actually getting they
marketed it as
an like a fresh inside look like see the
real hillary
yeah that it's really see the hillary
through her eyes well and i think you
know you think about documentary films i
know i'm trying to think i feel like the
first documentary filmmaker i was ever
really aware of was probably like
michael moore
and then errol morris and i don't know
like we could say a lot of you know
there's a lot of criticism to be made of
i guess both of them but like with
michael moore at least
i was like okay a documentary is when
someone investigates something that
might make people look bad and ask
difficult questions and maybe makes
things uncomfortable
trying to get at a truth of some sort or
like with an errol morris film like you
know
uh thin blue line or thin red line i
guess it's confusing
blue line blue one yeah you know it gets
at this idea of
you know he's asking really hard
questions about a a court case and
someone eventually gets freed because of
it there's this sort of like desire
for the truth via film and i think
that's the question and maybe this is me
being too idealistic but i think at its
best
documentary filmmaking is trying to
uncover a concealed truth
or get to the bottom of something and i
think a lot of the documentaries that
you know come up in that
article alec and things were talking
about aren't doing that they're trying
to
use reality for entertainment's sake or
to
create that like hey geographic cinema
yeah
well so if
there's nothing there's nothing left on
that one um
you know and also too like let us know
documentaries you
really like ones you think do this well
or maybe let us know if you think we're
just being cranky and all this is fine
and uh you can do that
whenever you want via phone via email
and uh via post if you can find any of
our home addresses
so uh phone number call us at two one
three five three four eight eight zero
seven that's two in three five three
four eight eight zero seven just so you
know it's a voice mail so if you're
expecting alex voice to be there
on the other end he's not gonna be there
to live chat with you but you can leave
a voicemail
we will listen we love it when you call
if you're more of a fingers on the keys
type person
culture binge at wisecrack dot co as
always there is no
m so culture binge at wisecrack.com we
love
to hear from you whether that's about
influencers
about workplace jacking and about
documentary puff pieces we want to hear
about all of that
and more and even stuff you want to hear
us talk about we'd love to do it so
alec uh what do we have this time for
people who have hit us up
we've got a voicemail from ross about
last week we talked about relationships
during covet and
maybe going very bad or very well uh
joy can you play that hey culture bin
folks this is uh
ross from dc i just wanted to respond to
what you had mentioned about like
relationships during the time of covid
i'm in a somewhat unique position
um my wife and i moved back in with her
folks just before covet had started
because we were expecting our first
child
and we also wanted to save money to buy
a house so
in november of 2010 sorry 2019
our daughter was born and then in march
we all went under lockdown and so i was
actually living in a house with my wife
my daughter my mother-in-law my
father-in-law my sister-in-law
and my sister-in-law's child who was
born two and a half months after
mine um it was fascinating
and having like at least three arguments
before lunchtime meant that we were
doing our jobs right
but i think one of the things that's
been interesting about kind of living
under the microscope not to like go with
sartre
is that like there's a way in which
being under constant observation
challenged who i thought i was as a
person in a way like having like
four or five memories that i said this
defines me absolutely the case
but then realizing that most of my day
is spent like doing menial tasks
kind of just regular existence you know
kind of farting when i think nobody is
listening
and then also attending to the needs of
my daughter made me realize oh
like there's a lot more to who i am but
there's also a lot less to who i am and
a lot more of this but now
um thankfully my wife and i are as
strong as we've ever been
we've since moved into our own home with
our daughter um
yeah couldn't have done what we did
without the help
of the family around and also being a
white american
living in a traditional indian household
for nearly a year
was illuminating and made me realize how
important it is to have family around
because um we're so caught up in the
sort of like
nuclear options of just like having like
mom dad and that's it but having
all the support around having all of
these conversations
made it very interesting even if we came
dangerously close to the maximum amount
of people that we were allowed to have
in one spot uh
so thanks for listening to the ramble i
love everything that you all do can't
wait every time you come out with the
episode and um sorry we're still waiting
on that mukbang thank you so much for
everything yeah mukbang
oh my bang indian food oh my gosh that
was my first thought i was like you have
to eat good for a year probably
um thank you so much ross that's really
interesting and i think that his
his comment there about the sartre thing
i wasn't sure where he was going with
that but that makes such perfect sense
the idea of
you know being caught in the gaze of the
other and being the you know the object
of another person's subjectivity does
call into question so many things about
our being
and so often we can just like be alone
so that isn't a really interesting like
social experiment but also
especially for example yes oh boy
but yeah well i'm i'm trying to
compliment ross on this sort of like uh
existential analysis he did on himself
during this period and all allah can
think about is a 60 year old man jerking
it
yeah we know where you're minded i
i love this voicemail it's so
interesting and i'm very curious how
um ross felt about being immersed in a
different culture for so long
because for me having multi-generational
households or having a lot of family
around
is quite normal but for someone that's
like from a different culture especially
in american culture where things are
more individualistic and an indian
culture is more collectivistic
i'm curious how that felt like was that
was that a huge shock at first like for
your mother-in-law to be like oh here
i'll watch your child or like oh i made
your bed
like was that weird for you at first did
you come to like it
have you felt like your culture like
your your personal
um culture like the culture that you
want to have with your
wife and your child like has that
changed at all so if you could
write back that would be good call back
ross leave a 15-minute detail message
with the anthropological perspectives
you've gained in this
no that's awesome though um do we have
any other voicemails no other voicemails
uh
great please do call us and leave them
uh try to keep them to about a minute
but we do have some emails uh the first
one's a really interesting email from
brian
uh last a week or a few weeks ago we're
talking about
the influencer party houses uh here's
brian's email really enjoyed the episode
on the party house controversies
happening in l.a
i too on the surface initially cast
blame on the young and wealthy people
who disturbed the neighborhood piece by
throwing large non-coveted friendly
events for new content
that's until i read an article by
bloomberg about the talent the talent
management firms
who rent out these large houses in
well-off parts of la and essentially
rent them out
in kind to young influencers in exchange
for a set amount of new content on a
week-to-week basis
i again was forced to challenge my own
biases and consider the possibilities
that is not
all the fault of irresponsible young
people but of profit-seeking firms
looking to make money off whatever the
latest true trend is
i haven't read this bloomberg article
that sounds super interesting and makes
sense
that i would hope
god i would hope still that there's like
a better way to make content
but and i'm not gonna excuse the parties
but
i think that's a really interesting
perspective
yeah it makes you think there's um
there's some run the jewel song
where killer mike says some verse and
it's something like
he's looking at the man behind the man
behind the man behind the man the point
being like there's
often like systems of power and
corruption that get off the hook because
we focus on the thing right in front of
us
so that does sound kind of interesting
that like you know we can say that these
these
young influencers are just like
obnoxious covet truth or douchebags but
it might also be the case that there's
larger forces pulling strings behind
there and then putting them in these
situations so
i want to check that article out yeah
thanks for the email that was great
uh the next email is from sean about
relationships
a lot of people having some issues or
maybe non-issues while
in lockdown uh this john i wanted to
share one thought with regards to the
conversation about online dating apps in
the latest episode
in general as a single person i hate
dating apps and i agree that i very much
miss the days of meeting people
organically
that being said i find there's a lot of
stress anxiety for me at least with
approaching people in public for the
first time
i don't want to be the person bothering
them if they're they're just for a night
out with friends or are in a really
relationship already or for whatever
other reason don't want to be bothered
by someone like me
one silver lining that i've realized
from using the apps that at least you
know the other people on there are also
interested in entertaining the
possibility of something romantic
once it is determined if there's a spark
or not there isn't even that fear
that you're bothering the person or at
least with respect to your interest in
dating
obviously the potential creepiness of
dudes can still be a bother but that's
an issue you've already discussed
uh sorry i i miss i misintroduced this
one this is about online dating apps
which is we just talk about
you know [ __ ] and jerking and dating
and all that stuff all the time
uh yeah this is the eternal question
as someone i really got burns with that
one
uh so what do you guys think
i think that there is something
relieving about being on a dating app
because you know that that person's
there for
a specific reason they want to meet
somebody else and then the
question is do you want something
long-term or short-term or what are you
looking for exactly but at least you
know that person
is open to to communication about this
so i agree i think dating apps are great
and
i get nervous if a guy approaches me in
person
just because i just kind of get nervous
around humans in general
um so i i i think i might be sort of
like okay thank you bye
because i just get nervous it just has
nothing to do with a guy it's completely
a personal issue no yeah that email
sounds really spot on and he has a good
perspective on that it makes me miss the
days well i wasn't alive during these
days but
like in the 70s i know in a lot of
cities like chicago they had a bunch of
like singles bars which were bars that
you went to
if you wanted to meet people so you kind
of knew like if you go to this bar
people
are kind of like interested in meeting
each other so you're not being as creepy
but it
also makes me think i just read a dieses
and marrows book
god level knowledge darts that came out
which is very funny and insightful and
they had a section on dating and there
was a part where it's sort of like
but what if i see a woman on the train
we lock eyes and
i know that we have a special connection
and they're just like bro you don't
don't be a creep
and you know often there is a thing and
like i'm sure i've been guilty of this
where
i think men especially can create
narratives by which like oh
i know this woman is like at the
doctor's office right now and she has
like a compound fracture and she's
crying but like
maybe i need to walk across the
emergency room and spit game because
this is my moment
and and i think that like there is
something to be said for like not
being a creepy dude and dating apps
creating those conditions so
yeah i think we all agree on this it's
it's rough out there and i don't
i don't envy anyone who has to date
right now and on another episode i'll
complain more about one of my friends
who's dating right now who's like
going home with people after one night
and i just think it's the most
horrifying thing ever and there's a
pandemic and what are you doing with
your life but he doesn't listen to this
podcast or whatever
yeah yeah there's someone for everyone
so
if you're looking around at least that's
what i keep telling myself
yeah there is was there just one in some
case though so if you do not find them
you will die alone i'm kidding sorry
it's horrible uh any other emails
for this yeah we got one last one from
joshua this one's about relationships
i'm sorry i'm a dumb dumb
uh no you're not you're great thank you
i'm writing uh
regarding relationships through covid
the end of 2019 i was considered
proposing to my girlfriend of five years
i've been forced to work from home and
my girlfriend has lost all of her work
in live theater
we both have suffered from depression in
the past i was initially worried for us
getting through this whole situation
due to all the compacting stresses many
friends of mine have one to break up and
one met a person that married him during
the quarantine that is
very intense whoa yeah throughout this
pandemic i've actually been incredibly
reassured in the strength of my
relationship
i encountered uh encountered encourage i
think they mean encouraged i encouraged
my girlfriend to start her own online
shop
and she has uh pushed her boy to paint d
d miniatures which i've always wanted to
do but never felt i had the time to take
up
uh we have worked on our communicating
practice dancing together she taught me
how to make my own pajamas i've taught
her spanish
and we've had huge gaming sessions
together that sounds magical
this couple is awesome yeah i know a lot
of couples are struggling i wish them
the best but i thought y'all could use a
rose that grew through the concrete
during all the misery of 2020.
and hey if your relationship isn't uh as
maybe beautiful as this one don't don't
feel bad
it everyone's different but yeah
i love this email when i read it i was
having the worst day and i read this
email and it just
made me so happy i was like this is so
wonderful i'm like this is so nice to
hear
that that a couple took this time and
they were able to strengthen their
relationship so thank you so much for
sharing
that's amazing it really made me happy i
hope you all get married and stay
together forever
and you deserve all the happiness in the
world and if you want wisecrack we'll
sponsor your wedding yeah we'll sponsor
your wedding
uh michael will officiate it uh i think
philosophers are allowed to officiate
weddings right
yeah most definitely yeah that's the
thing um great well so thanks again
everyone for calling emailing
we say it every time we really mean it
we love this stuff even the ones we
don't have time to read or listen to it
makes us so happy to hear from you all
and sadly some things get cut for time
but once again culture binge
wisecrack.com is where you can email us
2135348807
is where you can call us in the meantime
we'll be really quick we're growing so
long today
if people want to find you in the
meantime serbie where do they do it
sir patel 22 on twitter alec where are
you
twitter at wisecrack alec cool i'm
michael o'burns on all the social media
stuff
follow us find us don't be creeps be
friends and we'll catch you in a couple
weeks this has been culture binge
see you guys later bye
[Music]
you